it says here with merdot maharami um
who's a student of vijay subramanian at
university of michigan and uh jamming
zoo who's at duke
um so um i probably don't need to tell
you
that there's this interest in planted
problems
so you know you have some constraint
satisfaction problem or optimization
problem and it has a good
solution built into the instance somehow
um typically with some randomness and
then with some
randomness on top some additional noise
and then we have all these interesting
questions like
when can we find that good solution
exactly or approximately
and one nice you know obviously one nice
application of this
is inference where the hidden solution
is in fact some kind of ground truth
which we're trying to discover and so
our picture is we're trying to infer
a ground truth from noisy data
data which has been passed through some
kind of noisy channel
some kind of generative process that
started with that ground data and then
added stuff
one of my favorite applications of this
is community detection and networks
but i won't be talking about that i just
wanted to have you have some color on
the screen briefly
and then as you know if you've been
hanging out here
here this semester there are information
theoretical barriers
beyond which the data just doesn't carry
enough information for you to solve this
problem and then there are computational
barriers
where the problem is information
theoretically possible but it might be
computationally intractable
and um physics has been a nice source of
conjectures and occasionally proof ideas
or even algorithmic ideas in this field
so um here is a figure from a pnas paper
from 10 years ago
here's the idea i have a video
of a flock of birds or a bunch of
bacteria swimming around
under a microscope and let's just focus
on two frames of this video
i want to match the objects in one frame
to the objects in the next frame so that
over the course of many frames i can
really track
their trajectories moving uh through
time
and but of course these are frames
they're snapshots
so one reasonable thing to do would be
to assume
some prior about how much displacement
you would see from in a given one of
these
objects from one frame to the next and
then
do some kind of minimum matching or
maximum likelihood matching
so that was their motivation now they
were interested
in a kind of obviously a spatial version
of this problem
i'm actually going to be looking at an
even simpler version of this problem but
which i
think is still very interesting so we're
going to have a complete
weighted bipartite graph with n vertices
on either side
there is going to be a hidden or planted
perfect matching m
those are the red edges of course what
i'm actually going to do is scramble up
the vertices randomly
they won't you know they won't be the
edges uh going straight across
and then each edge in this network will
have some
randomly chosen weight but the point is
that
the planted edges will have their
weights chosen from
a different distribution p than
the unplanted edges uh whose
distribution will be called
q and as you can imagine we're going to
make the planted edges significantly
lighter
so that they're fairly likely to show up
in the minimum weight matching
actually we're going to i let me say
something better in a moment but so i
show you this weighted bipartite graph
and i challenge you
recover the minimum matching sorry
recover the planted matching
um exactly or approximately
so i'm going to focus on the case where
both of these distributions are
exponential
excuse me
i used to parametrize exponential
distributions in terms of their
expectation
but i've fallen in with a bad crowd who
does it by their rate
so um the uh planted edges
will be exponential with rate lambda
which means their mean
is one over lambda and the unplanted
edges will be exponential with rate
one over n which means their mean is n
so lambda is going to be some constant
order one so why
is this the right scaling to look for a
phase transition
um well as you can as you can see if
the unplanted edges of which each vertex
has
n minus 1 have our exponential with mean
n then the lightest one will be
exponential with mean
about 1. so this scaling
where the planted edges have mean order
one
and the unplanted edges have mean n is
where the planted edges start to compete
with the lightest unplanted edges
um now with these exponentials and this
is what i
should have said before with these
exponentials the minimum weight matching
is in fact also the maximum likelihood
estimate
of the planted matching you know because
you take the log likelihoods and
well you know they were exponential
before and
you you see it hopefully um if i had
some other distribution this would not
be quite
true so um here the weights themselves
are uh linear related to the log
likelihood
so our question now is
in this ensemble of random instances
excuse me
um how much does the minimum weight
matching m hat have in common
with the planted matching m
and where i'm going to show you that
there's a phase transition
in this parameter lambda and give you
some exact results
on both sides of that phase transition
so here's our theorem the overlap which
is the
the expected overlap the expected
fraction of edges
that the planted matching and minimum
matching have in common is
this thing on the right if lambda is
bigger than four which
means again that the mean weight of the
planted edges is less than one quarter
this tends to one in other words you get
almost
perfect recovery the the minimum weight
matching is almost identical
to the planted one when lambda is less
than
four we have a function of lambda which
is given by this integral
which is has to do with these four
functions which are the solution
to this system of ordinary differential
equations with these boundary conditions
on the bottom
ah you know who who ordered that where
the heck did this come from
um so that's what i'm going to show you
this is not you know whether you call
this an
explicit solution as a kind of a matter
of taste
we don't know how to solve this system
of differential equations in closed form
but of course we can integrate it
numerically and compute this function to
any precision we like
so in my book this is explicit enough
all right so here is a graph of this
function this
overlap again the the expected fraction
of
uh of edges they have in common and here
are the results the means of a bunch of
experiments
and in fact the error bars the
statistical error when you do many
independent experiments
are quite narrow here so we believe that
this concentrates around its expectation
although that's one of the things
that we haven't quite succeeded in
proving yet
all right so how uh yes can i ask a
question how many derivatives
uh equal to zero does that function have
oh my gosh that's one of the open
questions on my second to last slide
fair enough um although
it is now sorry just a few days ago i
learned from jamming that it is no
longer an open question
so hold that thought okay very good
question
all right so first let's prove that
there is almost perfect recovery
when lambda is bigger than four for this
we're going to use
the first moment method so as you recall
from your data structures and algorithms
course
uh any two matchings differ by an
alternating cycle and so
if there is any edge of the planted
matching which does not participate in
the minimum weight matching
that means it is part of some
alternating cycle where the total weight
of the blue
unplanted edges is less than the total
weight of the red planted edges
well um both of these weights
the the sum of the red weights and some
of the blue weights are respectively
the sum of uh several um
l if this whole thing has length 2l the
sum of l
independent exponential variables the
sum of l independent exponential
variables i learned something new every
day is called an
heirlang variable um i mentioned when i
gave this talk last time that i hadn't
heard of erlang
and this was kind of sad for david
gomarnik who has a
plaque on his office wall for having
received the erlang award
so i know erlang is a very important
person i just hadn't heard of him before
working on this problem anyway um
it's pretty easy by computing the moment
generating function to get a turnoff
style bound
a tail bound on the probability that one
of these air lanes is bigger than the
other erlang
and since one of these has mean l times
lambda and the other has mean
l times n you can imagine that that will
that will go down
exponentially with l
with n inside there and indeed it does
so then we just take a union bound over
all possible such augmenting cycles
of length l and we sum over all possible
l and we find out that
when lambda is bigger than 4 this
decreases exponentially with
l and so uh it's then the expected
number
of the total expected number of edges
that participate in all these augmenting
cycles
is then only order one when lambda is
greater than four
and so that tells you that the overlap
will be one minus
little of one aft because we're going to
divide by
n there um so
great so that's the proof of uh
almost perfect recovery when lambda is
bigger than four
now in order to tell you all this great
differential equation stuff that happens
when lambda is less than four
as a warm up i'm going to tell you
something that everyone should know
and that in this audience probably half
of you already do but it's a wonderful
story
what about the unplanted version of this
problem so
forget planted matching let's just say i
have a complete weighted bipartite
graph where the weights are either
uniform
in the interval from 0 to n or
exponential with mean and it doesn't
really matter
both of these distributions have density
1
or 1 over n close to weight 0.
what's the cost of the minimum matching
well this based on these wonderful
techniques we've heard about
from spin glass theory you know replica
symmetry and all that and i'll actually
sketch this for you
um ms arden parisi conjectured a value
for this
which is zeta of two pi squared over six
and um and it turns out actually even
something more wonderful is true
which is that if we do this for finite n
and vertices on either side
the expected value is the first n terms
of the series
one plus one quarter plus one ninth up
to one over n squared
ah so beautiful um so
ah this was then proved by aldis and
aldous and steele and indeed
proving this was partly why uh aldous
built this celebrated machinery of local
weak convergence so
how does this well kind of both the
physics version and aldous's rigorous
version
um you know follow the same theme
we're going to model this graph as a
tree
so there'll be a root here which is that
null
symbol it's going to have a countably
infinite number of
uh children starting you know labeled
one two three four
each of them have a countably infinite
number and so on
now you might say wait a second you know
it's one thing to say
that a sparse rendu graph or whatever is
locally tree-like
this is a complete bipartite graph it's
not locally tree-like at all
well yes but you can show
that with high probability only the
lightest edges
incident to each vertex will participate
in the minimum weight matching and so
when you count
those it's more like a degree login
graph than a degree n
graph and in that case it is
uh with high probability locality like
so now we're going to do again i need
you to go back to your undergraduate
algorithms and data structures class
we're going to do this kind of classic
dynamic programming approach to
computing the minimum weight matching on
this infinite tree
and this really is a kind of message
passing algorithm even though
no one told us this when we took that
undergraduate course
so um i'm going to define a random
variable for each one of the children
of this root node for child v
i'll call it x sub v and
it will be the cost
of matching the root node with v
and as opposed to matching the root node
with
none of its children one way to say that
is that the root node will actually be
matched with its parent farther up the
tree in which case why did i call it the
root but you know what i mean
the other way to say this is that it's
the difference
in uh the cost of the minimum matching
on um
uh the the sub tree starting at v versus
the
subtree starting consisting of its
children but not v
okay so if we have these
randomly chosen weights which i've
called those zetas zeta one zeta two
zeta three then
by matching the root with child number 2
there
it costs me the weight of that edge zeta
2.
on the other hand it releases that child
number 2
from the obligation to be matched with
any of its children
okay and so this gives us a nice little
recurrence relation
so first of all i need to tell you that
the way i'm going to arrange this tree
is i'm going to sort
the roots children one two three and
four
from lowest weight of their edge to the
root to highest weight
and now i'm going to remind you that if
you take
uh a bunch of independent draws from an
exponential distribution
um n of them as n tends to infinity
and um and then sort them from smallest
to largest
you get these poisson arrival times you
get the moments where
a geiger counter clicks or some poisson
process
some bell rings or something so um
they are and they have these exponential
gaps in between them
of mean one so the first one is
exponential with mean one
the second one is the sum of two of
those exponentials this
third one is that one plus one more and
so on
all right so if you were solving this
minimization problem you would say well
gee
if i'm committed to matching the route
to one of its it's
one of its children i which one would i
match it with
well i'll match it to the one where the
cost is minimal
over all i of the weight of that
edge zeta sub i minus
the cost of matching that child to one
of it its children
exabyte okay with me so far
all right so now this turns into a
distributional fixed point equation it's
a lovely question
if the zeta sub i's have a joint
distribution
which are these poisson arrival times
and the x sub eyes
are drawn from some are drawn
independently from some distribution
of these costs which you really should
think of as messages coming up through
the tree
and i use this procedure just to select
a new cost
x for the root node of matching it to
one of its children
well that will have some distribution
and now i want the distribution of x to
be the same
as the distribution from which the x sub
eyes were drawn from
so that's this distributional fixed
point equation what distribution could
that be
all right so i've just rewritten that up
here
and there's some lovely tricks for doing
this so
um you know this this the zeta sub is
seem like this potentially
complicated joint distribution these
poisson arrival times
um but i and and the x sub i's are drawn
independently from some distribution
that i don't know i'm trying to figure
it out
so there's a cute way to do this
consider a two dimensional poisson
process
where we're drawing zetas and x's
where the density of this poisson
process
is f of x that's that distribution of x
that we're trying to figure out
and then well the zetas really are just
drawn from a poisson process
in the vertical direction and so sorting
them
from lowest to highest smallest to
largest those will exactly be
those poisson arrivals as long as the
integral
overall x of the density is one which it
is because
that's the total density of
the integral overall x of f of x so then
what's the probability we're going to
compute the cumulative distribution
function of big x
what's the probability that it is
greater than some value
well it's the minimum of all these so
it's the probability that none of these
points
fall below this diagonal line
where um where zeta minus
little x is big x but for any poisson
process the probability that a region
has no points in it
is just e to the minus the total rate of
that region the total number of expected
points in that region
and that in itself is just the integral
of
uh a kind of shifted version of the
cumulative distribution function
of x so i hope i'm
um i hope you're still with me what we
get now
is this nice fixed point equation on the
bottom left
that the complementary cumulative
distribution function
the probability that big x is bigger
than some given x
is equal to this exponential of this
integral
happily now if we take the diff the
derivative of each side we just get a
little differential equation
for the cumulative distribution function
it's uh
looks kind of sweet it involves both f
of x and f of minus x
solving it takes a little bit of work
you first have to realize that in fact
um the distribution will be
uh symmetric around the origin
and then you get this exact solution
so now that we know the distribution of
these costs
we can kind of compute anything we want
in particular
now we're going to answer this original
question what is the cost
of the minimum matching well consider
some edge
um and let's say it has weight w it's
handy to think of now a bi-infinite tree
thinking of these
uh trees dangling from each of that
edges endpoints
when would you include that edge in the
minimum matching
well you would include that whenever its
weight w
is less than the total cost of matching
both of its endpoints to one of their
children
instead of to each other but we can
compute all of this now
so it's the it's the the the expected
weight
is the expectation of the weight times
this indicator random variable
that the weight is less than the sum of
those two costs
um you do an integral you do some
simplifications
it turns out to have to do with the
variance of the distribution and you get
pi
squared over six okay good
so in a sense this was the physics proof
because i didn't do the rigorous stuff
about
why is it okay to model this process
with the infinite tree and so on
um i will briefly address that at the
end
so basically what we wanted to do was
now
do all of this again but with two kinds
of edges
and so the the physics part of it
is simply a more elaborate version of
the physics part of the unplanted
version
so now the root let's say its
planted partner is one of its children
we'll call it child
zero and we'll call the weight of its
planted edge
eta so that's drawn from the
distribution of planted weights
exponential with mean
lambda one over lambda and then we'll
take
all the unplanted uh neighbors of the
root
and again sort them from smallest to
largest weights those will again be the
zeta one zeta 2 zeta 3 and so on
now we have roughly the same kind of
recurrence we had before but it's a
little bit fancier because
now well what's the cost of matching the
root
with one of its children well it depends
on whether we match it with its planted
child
or one of its unplanted children but we
also have two types of
nodes in this tree because for instance
the planted child of the root its
planted
partner doesn't lead to one of its
children it leads to its parent the root
so now we have two distributions of
messages
one distribution coming up from the
nodes
whose planted partner is one of their
children
and the other coming up from those where
all of their children are their
unplanted partners because their planted
partner is their parent
as you can tell i had to practice this
several times to say it without
tripping over the uh the p's
okay so um so we now have a kind of
coupled pair
of these distributional fixed point
equations for these two different
distributions
and you can kind of see what's going on
we're taking the minimum
both over all i for the planted children
and
when you're planted child when your
planted partner is their child zero
over that weight okay so you can see
what's going on
now before we had this clever trick with
that two-dimensional poisson process
to translate this distributional fixed
point equation into an ordinary
differential equation it's worth pausing
for a moment and noting
that we don't normally know how to do
that
right i mean distributional fixed point
equations
operate in this infinitely high
dimensional space
of probability distributions over the
reals or whatever
and it's generally very hard to
show that they converge that their fixed
points are unique figure out what those
fixed points are
and and um and so on and
and for instance nike understands this
very well from her work on ksat
um so uh
before we got lucky and turned it into a
single ordinary differential equation
which we could just solve well here
we're
almost as lucky but not quite so we
write down
uh analogous to before a bunch of
functions
which are cumulative distribution
functions of these various costs
so one of them is you know the
probability that the cost
of matching with your best unplanted
child is less than blah
then there's a reflected version of it
then we found it useful to define
another one which is that convolved
with the distribution of planted weights
eta
and so on and so forth and then we were
able to translate
the recursive distributional equation
into a system of four
ordinary differential equations which
are coupled with each other
i want to mention that the first
two of these are kind of generic
the the ones for f and g would hold no
matter what the distribution of planted
weights was
but the second two those ones for v and
w
are specific to the exponential
distribution for the planted
weights so this is the point at which if
you said well why are you just doing the
exponential distribution
this is the point at which i would say
and i will again if i have to
for other distributions we don't know
how to reduce to a finite dimensional
system
of of ordinary differential equations um
you know for instance the the physicists
who wrote that paper about um
the the tracking the particles from one
frame to the next
they said well in brownian motion these
um
uh these displacements would be like the
norms of gaussians
in two or three dimensions so for
instance we don't know how to do this
calculation exactly for that case
you start you try you get higher and
higher moments it doesn't seem to close
you know we're not sure what to do but
for the exponential distribution
you can really just use integration by
parts
and uh and then things get much easier
all right now so here's the system of
differential equations
but of course this system doesn't know
that these are meant to be cumulative
distribution functions
i mean it will happily look for
solutions to this
which might be less than zero they might
be bigger than one
um we're interested in sensible
solutions
remember up there you you see the
definition of
of f on the upper left in red it's
really supposed to be a cumulative
distribution function
so it had better go from zero when z
when x is minus infinity
to one when x is plus infinity so
it's only those solutions that would
constitute fixed points
of the distributional equation all right
well now i already proved to you that
when lambda is bigger than
four we get almost perfect recovery
and that gets mirrored in this setting
by the fact that when lambda is bigger
than four there is no solution to these
differential equations
that gives reasonable looking things
that go from zero here to one over there
so in other words we don't get solutions
that make sense as
cdfs and this is not hard to prove
um what you end up thinking about is
okay well i know it i know it's supposed
to happen
when x is minus infinity and when x is
plus infinity
uh but i have to choose a so-called
initial condition when x is zero
no matter what you choose you can show
that these functions will
exceed one or dive below zero
so i'm going to skip this proof you can
it there's a little conservation law
which is handy
which reduces the system from four four
independent
uh functions to three so the proof is
not very hard
anyways there's no solution when lambda
is bigger than four
now uh one of our open questions is
well gee suppose suppose we didn't feel
like doing that first
moment argument i showed you before
where we actually counted
the expected number of augmenting cycles
it seems like this ought to be a proof
of almost perfect recovery because
what's going on here
is that if you started with any initial
distribution of these costs and iterated
the recursion you would find that the
cost
of using an unplanted edge
goes off to infinity okay so there's no
stable distribution
that lives on the reels so this should
be some
alternate way to prove that but we
i'm not sure how to make that fly but
it's i think it's very nice that that
combinatorial fact
about uh almost perfect recovery because
there are very few augmenting cycles
with high probability gets mirrored in
this continuous dynamical setting here
by the solutions flying outside the unit
interval
um good well now what about when lambda
is less than 4
where we had that theorem which you can
see i'm working toward
um well again we so we we reduce to the
three-dimensional system using that
conservation law
the details don't really matter the
point is that it turns out there is a
unique initial condition a unique
setting
of one of these functions at x equal to
0
such that this will tend to
1 as x goes to infinity which is what a
cumulative distribution function ought
to do
and also to zero as x goes to minus
infinity
and the reason it's unique is very sweet
it's really because
the point at infinity we're trying to
arrive at is dynamically speaking a
saddle point
so um so it's this it's this point that
x goes to infinity where
where these cdfs are tending to to one
and the kind of reflected the
complementary cdfs
are tending to zero if your initial
condition
at x equals zero is just a bit too high
you miss the saddle point and zoom off
to plus infinity
if it's a bit too low you dive down
below zero
and in either case you have a sensible
cdf it's only this unique fixed point
where you will ride in along what
dynamical systems people call the
unstable manifold
and come in along that you know ridge of
the saddle
and converge to it as opposed to falling
off the ridge
to one side or the other so i just you
know i
i really like when continuous math helps
us solve
discrete probabilistic math so anyway
um good here is the results of a
numerical experiment where we
do this type of numerics called
population dynamics where you have a bag
of a million numbers
that are supposed to be drawn from this
distribution and you repeatedly draw
them out of the bag
and do the recurrence and put them back
in um
and you know it does seem to converge
quite cleanly to
our predictions you know you should
always confirm your theorem
with an experiment
good so finally just as before we
computed the weight which we can also
compute here
let's compute the overlap consider a
particular
edge a red edge a planted edge it has a
random weight eta
we will include it in the minimum weight
matching if eta is less than
as before the sum of the costs of
matching the
its endpoints to one of their children
the total probability this happens is
again just an integral
but we can do this integral because we
have these functions
or actually we can't actually do it but
we can write it down
and finally at that bottom line there we
get the thing i put in my therm
okay so that's
um kind of the analytic physics-y part
of the proof
now i want to briefly uh
try to explain the rigorous part of the
proof
how does this you know what license do
we have
to model this infinite uh sorry this
large but finite randomly weighted
bipartite graph
with this infinite tree this is quite
subtle and as you can imagine this is
why our paper has a 40 page appendix
and frankly much of this is almost a
rewrite
of uh aldous and aldous and steel
um these are papers that we found
challenging to read and comprehend but
they are
they're beautiful but it's very subtle
stuff and it also changed
a lot sort of in the style of exposition
as all just went through this and
streamlined certain parts of it
um so i'm just going to say a little bit
about this
one thing to realize is that if you just
laid out this infinite weighted tree
if you took too literally the idea of
finding the minimum matching
you would say oh well i know how to do
that it's just you know it's going to be
for instance what would happen if i used
a greedy algorithm i'll take the root
match it with its lightest edge one of
its children
and then iterate well this isn't what we
want
actually the reason is that
the finite graphs that we're modeling
the problem has a great deal of symmetry
if i take any vertex there is an element
of the automorphism group where i swap
that vertex with
any other vertex that you choose to call
the root
and obviously nothing happens to the
joint distribution of all the weights
we have to be a little bit careful on
the planted thing to match
red edges to red edges and blue edges to
blue edges but that's not that hard
uh in particular you know if you are
if you're swapping the root with the
plant it's planted partner well
well then you really do swap it so that
red edge stays red and
and so on you can see what to do um
so as a result we are only interested in
distributions of matchings on the
infinite tree or actually joint
distributions
of weights and matchings which have
this spatial invariance for involution
and variance
they have to obey that if i swap any
vertex anywhere in the tree it suffices
to look at the immediate
uh children of the root then everything
will stay the same
so what we've done following aldonaldis
and steel
is construct an involution invariant
matching
with them with the lowest possible
minimum
cost and computed its cost and its
overlap
going back and forth between the
infinite tree and the finite graphs
is tricky and involves a bunch of
topology
the easy direction is that if i look
at an infinite sequence of
finite graphs and i
look at you know kind of the entire
world in the vicinity of some vertex the
you know which edges are planted and
which are not what their weights are
and which uh edges are included in the
minimum matching
this distribution converges to some
distribution on the infinite tree
so that's you know a kind of standard
compactness argument
the hard part is going in the opposite
direction the hard part is saying that
if i have this involution invariant
object on the infinite tree i can
actually map
that back onto finite weighted graphs
and get a sequence of matchings that
converges to it
so i'm not going to say very much about
this
one thing that helps along the way
is that uh as you know
well let's see it's a little tricky i so
in terms of like burkhoff's theorem
right
i mean any doubly stochastic matrix we
can think of
as a probability distribution over
permutation matrices
so if you like you can think in terms of
fractional matchings
where i compute for each vertex the
marginal probability that it's matched
to each of its neighbors
and then in this matrix you know the
rows have to sum to one and
sort of the columns and so on if we
could actually compute those marginals
what we actually do is compute this on
larger and larger sequences
of uh sorry sequences of larger and
larger neighborhoods
in the infinite tree the probabilities
don't quite some
sum to one because we're also not
looking at all of the children
of the uh of the root vertex only some
number of them
anyway so we get an almost
stochastic matrix which can get
translated
which can get translated back to an
almost perfect matching
on the finite bipartite graphs and then
we
reuse essentially a uh a lemma of aldus
that says you can then fix a small
number of edges
and we have to be careful and and merdog
by the way did a lot of work on this
um anyway then there's this cool
uniqueness property
that any invariant matching on the
infinite tree that differs from the
matching we found
has strictly greater expected cost
this is interesting and it involves some
some
arguments that seem very special to the
matching problem
the first step which is not special to
the matching problem is to say oh well
if both of these are are spatially
invariant then if they differ
anywhere then they differ with positive
probability at the root because wherever
they differ we could swap that with the
root
then you look there and you use some
special purpose arguments again
following aldous
that says oh well that means that if it
differs at the root
you're often choosing the wrong partner
not the partner that the kind of dynamic
programming
message passing algorithm told you to do
and um
you know but the right partner is given
by our differential equations and the
wrong partner has
strictly greater cost and so you're
going to have strictly greater
expected cost so when you put all this
together and i do think by the way if
you've been wanting to learn about this
you could do worse than read our
appendix because we did try to digest
these papers by aldus and kind of
explain the things that
we had trouble with um so
anyway uh finally yes
finally the limiting overlap uh and
cost of uh in expectation
on the finite graph converges to that on
the infinite tree
all righty here are some open questions
one is
ahmed's question what is the order of
this phase transition you know the giant
component is can in random graphs is
continuous
but it's first derivatives is
discontinuous
some other thing you know in physics we
call a phase transition
pith order if the first p
minus one actually for historical
reasons
uh of the derivatives are continuous
well um it turns out and
i learned this too recently to update
the slides
jaming and his collaborators just proved
that in fact
it's infinite order and this proved a
conjecture that came
in a physics paper also very recently
from gam sameergien and lancos devarova
and someone else whose names are later
on the slide so i better say it now
sukuro
and i'm sorry i don't have jemming's um
collaborators written here i can look up
my i can look up the email anyway
um so it's infinite order which is
pretty cool
it's all of the derivatives are
continuous there
so that's one question another question
is as i mentioned before
we only computed the expected overlap
and also i didn't show you but the
expected weight
it really ought to concentrate
numerically it looks as if it
concentrates it really looks as if the
uh the variance goes down like one over
n
now that's what you would expect if you
had some kind of correlation decay
and you might think well wait a second
you showed this
thing on the infinite tree and you
showed this uniqueness
uh this unique distribution of these
messages surely that means
that if i feed in arbitrary messages at
the leaves of the tree and iterate
through many layers that the root
doesn't care very much
about what i fed in down here so the
correlation should decay and when you
translate that back
to uh the finite graphs
then two vertices which are distant
distant in the weighted sense
the where the distance is the uh the
total weight
the the weighted shortest path between
them they should
you know it should be it asymptotically
independent whether this edge
here or that edge there is included in
the minimum matching
the stuff on the infinite tree is very
subtle though and we
and frankly it's a bit above my pay
grade and
maybe you can work it out but it doesn't
we don't quite seem to have the
correlation decay
or spatial mixing that we would want i'm
sure it's true
i'm sure someone can prove it but so far
we don't have that concentration
what about information theoretically
optimal recovery well
you know keep in mind this minimum
weight matching that's the maximum
likelihood estimate of the matching
but what you actually want to do to
maximize the overlap
is compute the marginal probability that
each edge
is one of the planted edges and then
take
the n most likely edges in that marginal
sense
that is the estimator which would
maximize the overlap
okay um it's this old you know it's this
question
do i pay you a million dollars if you
get the plant planted matching
completely right
and nothing if you get any edges wrong
if that's the game we're playing you
should use the maximum likelihood
estimator
but if i'm going to pay you one dollar
for each planted edge that you correctly
identify instead you should compute
those marginals
so that would be some kind of message
passing
at non-zero temperature right so rather
than
doing that minimizing over all of these
things you would do something more
bayesian you would really you would
literally be doing
like gibb sampling um we don't know how
to analyze that
uh i don't think we've completely
exhausted our efforts
but for instance i have no idea how to
write down a set of ordinary
differential equations for that
recursive distributional equation i'm
not saying it's impossible we haven't
done it yet
and then finally as i mentioned we have
distributions other than exponential
it's hard for them to collapse to
ordinary differential equations in that
case
there is a nice bound on message passing
um which xiaoming found and that that
bound was given by guim
and i'm sorry i don't know the first
name sakura and lancasterova
um and then jaming observed that it
matches the first moment bound
gotten from augmenting cycles
um and of course you could really if you
want you could really consider the
spatial version
of this which was that particle tracking
version
uh originally um
you know and i think uh there are a lot
of things you could plant in a weighted
graph
you could plant a spanning tree and then
uh you know where the edges the planted
spanning tree are lighter typically than
the other edges and asked to what extent
is the
minimum weight spanning for you or the
most or the uh you know
uh you know yeah the minimum weight
spanning tree would again be some kind
of mle if the weights were exponential
and so on
and what about traveling salespeople
paths and so on
and this also gets into a lot of the
work that a number of great people have
worked on
on noisy graph isomorphism
all right oh yeah you should buy this
book okay thank you very much for
inviting me to speak
okay thanks so much chris for the
lecture um so uh
while other people might be thinking of
questions uh i guess i just have a quick
one about the
posterior marginals um do you
know how to if you had them would you be
able to round them to a true matching
excellent question so you're absolutely
right
that if i compute the marginals
um on the edges and i take the top
n this might not even be a matching
and at this point i think you sort of
have to let's see
so your your question is what if
you you want among all matchings
so you want an estimator supported on
matchings
which subject to that constraint
maximizes the overlap
i guess yeah or or do you have a sense
that if you took the best uh
and edges is that close to a matching or
um okay geez when i was at microsoft i
know jumping and i talked about this
i am embarrassed to say
i don't know but i don't i don't think
it is a matching in general it is
probably close to one yes
i mean you know you you oh hey
drumming's on the call
yeah so chris if you don't mind i can
actually jump in and then
yes please okay so remember so i
tell us if if we take the n n edges with
the largest marginal probability
yeah so i think okay so if you take a n
entries with the largest probability
this may not be matching but you can do
projection in the sense that
find the closest matching um
to to to this like and particular edges
in terms of hamming distance
so that one i think will also get a um
like pretty good overlap
so and we know that it is close enough
to a matching so that not very much will
happen to the overlap when we do that
yeah so i think if you do that you will
probably lose a factor too
in terms of like optimal overlap oh yes
i'm sorry i do remember working this out
with you now
yes
this almost doubles the error it almost
doubles the number of planted edges that
we miss
yeah like another way is actually just
directly sampled from the posterior
distribution
so so you draw a random sample from the
posterior so that will be a matching by
definition
so that will also achieve the optimal
overlap up to a factor two
so it's like yeah so like in terms of
for example if you want to show the
optimal overlap it's a
uh uh sorry like uh okay yeah like uh
why do you look like one minus the
optimal overlapping factor sorry
why do you lose a factor too if you
sample from the posterior
yeah so i think there's a little bit of
um okay so i
i want to correct myself so uh in terms
of error not in terms of optimal overlap
so
so minus one minus optimum overlap so in
terms of that quantity if you do
posterior sampling that will be up to
like a factor two
at most yeah comparing to if you do
marginal posterior like
right so so the the in terms of
maximizing the overlap minimizing the
the
uh hamming distance if you will between
my estimated list of n edges and the
planted matching
with that loss function the optimal
estimator is not in general
matching which is kind of charming
um but if you projec
if you restrict to matchings you can get
an estimator which at most
has twice the hamming distance from the
planet crashing
uh are there other questions
i have a question hey chris this is
great
so i have a technical question about
that hard direction in the
in the construction of this proof so
each other
told us about this greedy algorithm on
the tree that constructs a minimum
uh weights matching but it's not
realizable on a
in terms of finite graph because it
doesn't satisfy this uh
invariants and they're the three
automorphisms right
um right i mean exactly it does
it its lack of invariance means it
doesn't map
back to a joint distribution on the uh
on the finite graphs so now you you're
going to have to think about what kind
of
constraints you have to add to this to
this uh
infinite in this minimum watch matching
in the infinite tree such that you can
map it back to a finite graph and it
seems like
you only need it to be invariant under
the three automorphisms in order to
be back right is that am i right in
saying this
uh yes and and the tree automorphisms
are generated by swaps between the root
and its children
ah so it suffices it suffices to think
about
i mean it this is very this is all very
cavity method stuff right so
it suffices to think about uh an edge
coming out of the route what message
what cost would be transmitted there
produced by all the
roots other children and then the
iteration versus what would be coming up
along that same edge i see so along
along every edge the distribution of
messages
um has to be the same and then because
these are two disjoint trees
they're independent and um
jamming do you want to add anything to
this or
um yeah so i actually don't have much to
say but i think there's
for this hard uh direction another
difficulty is that i think as
chris mentioned like so from this
infinite tree we can only get the
probability for a particular
edge to be in this optimal
matching and then that one is a fraction
number we somehow want to map it back
to a like a valid matching in a finite
graph
so then for every x yeah so somehow
then you have this uh like a matrix and
binary matrix somehow it doesn't really
exactly satisfy this double stochastic
constraint
so that's why i think we kind of run
into this we want first construct
this like almost perfect matching like
you allow a little bit of ip strong
like a wiggle room and then from this
like for this uh almost perfect matching
you can show
uh like the optimal cost is it it's
pretty much the same as the optimum
match in the tree
and then since you only need to change a
little bit of like epsilon fractions so
this won't
so you can turn this into the value of
the matching and this won't change too
much about the total cost in the end
so just i'll just say that i mean i i
got very attached to this picture of
fractional matchings because of course
by you know since matchings the
fractional matchings live in a
in a polytope and it's convex and the
vertices are the
genuine matchings if you can show that
fractional matching has a certain cost
there's always some vertex the polytope
genuine matching would that cost you
less i got very attracted to this
picture of things but then there's a
passage in aldous and steel that says
well actually
if you look at any edge in the infinite
tree and look at larger and larger
neighborhoods around that
the probability that this edge is
included in the minimum involution and
variant matching
tends to zero or one
that it doesn't for instance tend to one
half
but if that's true then why don't we
have spatial mixing i mean you just told
me
that the minimum matching is essentially
a deterministic object
where you're more and more certain about
it as you look at larger and larger
neighborhoods
and i'm still confused about this and
what one of the subtleties
is that which edges are included in the
minimum matching
is a function of the messages but you
could conceivably have different
sets of messages flowing around on the
tree but which agree on the matching
because the matching again
just has to do with these this
inequality on the messages and
i um i am still confused on this point
there are stronger properties that
people have shown for some
recursion recursive uh recursive
distributional equations
on trees like endogeny and there's this
work of uh
is it bando padie do i have that right
but we looked at those papers and felt
that they would be too hard to extend
those to the planted case
so as you can see there's a lot there's
a lot of subtleties here about how
unique the object
is on the infinite tree and what thing
exactly is unique and
whether the distant things matter or not
and uh
yeah you know it almost makes you want
to go back to physics
yeah thank you very much thanks a lot
okay any other questions
maybe i have one more uh short question
which is i guess after the eldest paper
there were
the papers that proved the result for
finite end it's a different proof
approach right
it's very different it's a sweet little
inductive proof
and and it only gives the oh sorry i
take that back
i believe it can be used to give the
expectation but also
the variance um
but you don't expect something like that
to
work in the planted setting that is a
great question
we looked at it and it didn't seem like
we could
make it fly in the planted setting also
frankly i mean i think i got excited
about working with jamming and merdot on
this problem
partly because i had wanted for years to
learn all just as proof
of the pi squared over six result so
that's
you know that's the direction we headed
in but
it's conceivable uh i think even in the
unplanted case
the the all this version covers more
distributions right
yes uh-huh yeah and i mean and all of
this in steel they simultaneously cover
um the unplanted versions of planted you
know other things like
spanning trees and um
k factors or you know uh hamiltonian
paths
i mean there's a lot of beautiful
subtleties here i'll just mention one
which i learned and again i'm i'm glad
jaming is here because all of this came
out from conversations with him
i mean what kind of object on the
infinite tree would correspond
to a hamiltonian path
for instance on a finite graph
well when you think about it it's this
beautiful thing
where every vertex
in the infinite tree has two paths that
lead out to infinity
right so it's out at infinity that they
all join up to form
a cycle similarly for a spanning tree
what should that be well it should be
it should be some kind of forest on the
infinite tree because
well the only spanning tree of the
infinite tree would be the whole thing
and that's obviously not what you meant
so i mean i i
i think one of the fascinating things is
what part of
the oldest and steel machinery applies
quite generically
to these optimization problems on
weighted graphs
and what part is kind of has to be
specially tailored
to the kind of object you're thinking
about
so it's it's very it's very beautiful
stuff
chris there's uh there's a like entire
class a course notes from about
these things right i don't know if you
read this like he has a combinatorial
optimization
and he treats it by using this
technology of local weak convergence and
the objective method and he like has a
bunch of examples i don't know if he
looks at this
oh we certainly talked with him a lot i
don't think i've read those lecture
notes that sounds great
okay i'll send you a link
chumming do you want to add anything
more before since you know
yeah thank you so much for the for the
great lecture um